happy to be with you mister
the FBI mr. Hoover experiment
it is an international communist menace the letter
becomes even more serious in this country as it
expands abroad all you have to do I think you in
South America in the last few days and view the
some of the very serious attacks a main opponent
vice president and his wife they were initiated by
covenant in those various countries and yet in
that one of those countries with the Communist
Party in the majority was a very small Bernard
and yet as I say they endanger the life of our
vice president in white coming since it destroyed
the American flag and he dispelled all the things
which expect I think that should be a lesson to
the folks in this town glad to hear you say that
there's been some talk Pakistan the vice-president
was simply a resentment against some of the
policies of our country you you feel it was
definitely a communist inspired I think that
is proven by the fact day and it's keeping that in
there many of the demonstrations while they were
supposed to have been conducted by students many
of the participants were found to be pushy within
their late 30s in putting all these they were not
students of the University address and from the
best information we have available there's been
a concerted effort to embarrass and if you won't
call just yesterday of a Moscow radio impressed
oh really there's almost a marked enthusiasm the
various demonstrations that have been made against
the vice president showing their condolences